[Music]
all right so about an hour ago at e3
Ubisoft announced officially Assassin's
Creed Odyssey we are kind of
time-traveling backward Michael got to
go to Ubisoft recently in Canada to try
out the game for about five hours but
it's been embargoed we can finally
publish this video Michael what are some
of the key strokes with Assassin's Creed
Odyssey that people might want to know
there are two things that stood out to
me is they're going all-in on being an
RPG now we got a little bit of that in
origins with like how the gear works out
and combat and stuff but they're going
all-in with branching dialogue almost
like Mass Effect and quest structure
very much like Witcher 3
she does right taking them head-on it
would be suicide sailing human suicide
right now my men are on the beach that's
where I'll be
now I straight-up asked them about like
oh did you get some inspiration from The
Witcher 3 like this is probably the best
design game in terms of how SciQuest
feed into the main story and they're
like yeah straight up like we looked at
with Witcher 3 and it really shows so
that's the probably the number one thing
that stood out to me yeah so I was gonna
say that always seems to be almost like
a feature bullet point on a lot of games
or branching dialogue meeting full of
choices but from your time it actually
seems like they are implementing it
yeah and that was kind of my impression
at first too because it's like oh you're
just gonna give me like three different
line lines to say to someone yeah just
like a different different ways to say
yes I'll help you with your quest or
whatever and it all leads to the same
Road and at first I was kind of like
okay this is this is cool I like having
some sort of agency and how the story
plays out and and also I what I realize
that they do affect later on down the
line like so there's dialogue choices
that you like what you say to people but
also what side quests you actually take
on and finish and how you finish them so
I didn't realize that at first because
in my five hours that I played there was
a there was a main line and then there
were side quests around it
and then by the time I got to the
conclusion of the main questline
that's when everything else I did kind
of I saw it play out at that at that
conclusion so it kind of sounds like
it's like kind of area specific though
right like you help these side quests in
this area you complete this this quest
in this area they kind of feed in like I
I mean you only got to see a slice right
like a certain area so I'm curious if
all of those regions sort of interlock
with characters as well or if it's just
area specific so I can't really say
because I've only I only spent time with
different islands but if they were
talking about going all-in as an RPG so
I would expect that to then that if
that's their their main message through
through revealing this game and also
from the demo that we saw I feel like
yeah I would expect that now to see that
throughout the entire game yeah this
this is the one thing that I felt was
missing in origins because Ubisoft was
doubling down on the fact that this is
an RPG you're gonna find Luke you're
gonna level up you can do all this but
there's no player agency in terms of
like the story you still follow by X
story and this seems pretty cool yeah
it's definitely here yeah despite being
an RPG there wasn't much role-playing
yeah glad what you're three do you like
it yeah I played a little bit of it I'm
just kidding Jake's played like six
times the game you were kind of lukewarm
on origins from what I remember I know
you like appreciated it but does that
actually you being probably the biggest
winter fan we know does that make you
excited for this even though it is the
first in a you know they renewed their
annual release schedule are you excited
for this yeah I'm excited in one of the
big reasons to I'm also excited was
because based on the gameplay you've
shown us than you captured this also is
like a follow up to to Black Flag which
is as someone who doesn't like
Assassin's Creed all that much that
one's my favorite it seems like that's a
similar story to most people like I
don't like Assassin's Creed that much
but I like Black Flag so I'm very
interested in that as well yeah Black
Flag was a very good pirate game with
Assassin's Creed elements exactly I love
Assassin's Creed I've played every game
at this point I really liked origins but
you yeah you tell me there was a naval
combat in origins when you were with the
name escapes Nia's by ex-partner you
were
that's commanding like the in a
flashback the Navy with her but you were
saying this is like full-on like island
hopping
yes naval focus with like ground combat
almost along decided instead of
overshadowing
[Music]
so black flag was like these long
stretches of nothing is it does it feel
more compressed this time or they're
like giant expansive seas with like an
island with a palm tree on it well the
thing is that at least looking at the
map again I only had access to two
islands but looking at the whole map it
seems like it's a huge map but the like
the actual sea is like you can get to
things pretty fast so I don't expect
there to be like a lot of open space
empty waters and wherever I was sailing
to there was always like Athenian ships
to attack so it wasn't it didn't feel
bare and instead so with origins a lot
of them the main thing for me is there
was a lot of just desert and there's
like nothing to do it's fine because
it's automatically fitting I suppose but
here it's like that same size map is now
now filled in with the sea and with this
whole naval combat approach and there's
at least from what I've saw so far is
that you know this naval combat is a lot
like Black Flag where you're boarding
ships after you take them down and
you're getting loot and there's missions
tied to that so I would expect at least
them to fill up the Seas with you know
fun and interesting things to do and
again from my five hour demo like I see
the I see it but I just want to make
sure that you know that's perpetuated
throughout the game did you care much
for origins and you play much of it
I appreciate what it did in terms of
okay we took the gear off and then we're
reinventing how combat works
yeah and we're building this character
of byuk I really like by it so that was
kind of my hook for origins yeah it's
which I like because again like Black
Flag was to me a very good pirate game
but the Assassin's Creed elements the
combat on the ground the way like they
still had those annoying quests where
you had to tell somebody for 10 minutes
hide in the bushes
an NPC is gonna run into you that stuff
the like the vestigial old Assassin's
Creed stuff annoyed me the idea of a new
Black Flag ish naval focus game with
actual
really good as Sasson screech stuff
attached to it sounds unreal and I'm
actually really happy they're going in
this direction yeah another thing too
who do you play in this game cuz you
don't play by right no it's not it's not
buying but so the main character is they
have Spartan routes but when you're
dropped into the game you're neither
like by definition you're neither
Spartan or Athenian and I expect that
you're supposed to kind of forge your
own path but at the outset you either
choose the male or female version of the
senior character so it's kind of like
that Mass Effect male Shepard and female
show yeah like they're there lines of
dialogue are the same the delivery
obviously is gonna be different because
of different voice actors I was hoping
when the smoke cleared us we could find
someone quiet but they are essentially
the same character and they're not like
was it jacob and evie from syndicate
yeah yeah oh so they're not both like in
the story it's like you pick one and
that's it it's one or the other
that'd be interesting I'm curious how
they're gonna do that with like I guess
Assassin's Creed lore like I wonder how
that will fit in but I mean I feel like
Assassin's Creed lawyers already like an
s like only a couple people I've really
yeah can ya nail it down a less
complicated timeline of the Zelda games
yeah it's something that I don't think
about my plan Assassin's Creed yeah so
did they say anything what's going on
historically at this point so this is a
prequel to origins right hmm while the
the modern-day story is a continuation
with Halo with all the Abstergo stuff
yeah so it's a continuation of that in
the present present day but I mean in
terms of the the theme with the ancient
Greece obviously that's before what
happened in origins we put this at the
very beginning of the timeline because
origins was the earliest was like for
hello or yes it was like not even if and
that's what some people definitely not
assess thank you good yeah and some
people are thinking like oh is this like
the maybe the Templars origin story or
something like that but I don't have
really any clues as to how this is gonna
tie into Assassin's Creed as a whole
story wise yeah
they were very I mean of course you want
to you want to keep that under wraps
what game comes out so honestly it's one
of those things I couldn't care less
about really like I'm just I just want
to play this I want to be a Spartan
pirate I don't really care about the
Abstergo assassin's stuff anymore
I mean I say I don't I secretly do but I
actually the historical stuff I mean if
they're going for Spartans and they
don't somehow touch on Thermopylae feel
like that would be weird and in that
case this would take place during like
the Persians invading the rest of the
world a desert seems like actually
playing a part in it who knows what's
actually happened this is taking place
during the Peloponnesian War like there
were 400 400 BC how about that spartan
kick though hey there's a lot more
together watch the gameplay yeah if you
just like a puke just enemies lined up
in front of you likewise a button you
just kick one after the other off the
boat and they fly like 20 feet
but that size into another thing too is
that the way they wish in which you use
the different abilities that are like
kind of tight shoulder buttons or the
left trigger left bumper so go into more
mechanics they have like the same like
skill trees and stuff but you can map so
many different abilities to when you
engage in combat and like I like I like
what origins did with their combat it's
kind of the same here in terms of feel
and how its kind of sluggish to me but
the fact that I have like Spartan kick
sand like shield breaks and so like I
can shoot like three arrows at the same
time this is this is also like a step
forward so it's a little bit more fun to
play because I I have all these tools
and so just like timing dodges and
parries yeah right there alright so
unless there are any major points you
want to hit on I think my main may be
not worry the thing I'm preoccupied with
and obviously like a lot of commenters
when they first announced the game on
Twitter we're saying oh they're going
back to yearly releases again and we
knew they would obviously use that
organs took a year off and it showed I
think they revamped the systems they
needed to from your who's had five hours
of the game or something over a week or
weekend are you coming away from that
demo up at Ubisoft excited or overall a
little bit coming off origins and then
moving on to playing Odyssey like I'm
genuinely excited for this because I
think the RPG elements is the thing that
does it for me because you know as as
fun as it is to explore these historical
open worlds you know having control of
what how the story plays out because is
that that means something to me and
assess tree has always been like here
we're gonna package a like story for you
like you are going to see a story unfold
but here you are an active participant
and I believe that you yourself can pull
it off especially with this witness demo
where you know I decided to let April I
let a prisoner live and I forgave him
like yo you you kill some people but I
think you can be a good person so I'm
gonna let you go and then in the
conclusion he ends up killing one of my
allies in retaliation for some reason
but like if it if there's a lot of those
moments sprinkled throughout the game
then I'm like constantly like thinking
about my decisions how do I tear this
quest
how do I conclude this side quest
because mmmm this person might pop up in
the main quest and those type of things
excited like you said all the other ones
like all the Assassin's Creed games
package a story for you that you follow
and having this I feel like adds a lot
more replay value like it's something to
talk about like oh this happened to me
what happened to you and plus like you
said also I think origins like while I
criticized that game a lot I think it
built a pretty solid foundation that
that hopefully I don't get sick up too
soon but only time will tell
yeah I was excited when they first
announced it but hearing your thoughts
on it put my mind at ease a little bit
more but anyway we have like four days
left to be three so see you guys later
peace out man
you